وفي ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه قالت حركه حماس
ان عمليه اطلاق النار في حواره رد طبيعي
على جرائم الاحتلال وعلى مجزره نابلس قبل
ايام واكدت حركه حماس ان المقاومه في
الضفه ستبقى حاضره ولن تستطيع اي خطه او
قمه ان توقفها حركه الجهاد الاسلامي باركت
عمليه حواره ووصفتها بالبطوليه مؤكده ان
العمليه تبعث برساله قويه الى اجتماع
العقبه بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه حاضره رغم
حجم المؤامره كما اشادت الجبهه الشعبيه
لتحرير فلسطين بعمليه اطلاق النار في
حواره مشيره الى ان هذه العمليه نوعيه من
حيث توقيتها ودلالاتها والرسائل الكبيره
الموجهه من خلالها ينضم الينا من رام الله
مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شماله سمير
ماذا في اخر المعلومات التي توفرت حول
ظروف هذه العمليه عمليه حواره
يعني ما هما مؤكد حتى هذه اللحظه حسب بيان
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وايضا المصادر
الطبيه الاسرائيليه بان
قتل مقتل مستوطنين في هذه الحادثه التي
نفذت في الشارع الرئيسي في داخل بلده حوار
الجنوبيه مدينه نابلس ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه
هناك تباين في طبيعه هذا الهجوم او شكل
هذا الهجوم كيف نفذ باتجاه هؤلاء هذين
المستوطنين ولكن احدى هذه الروايات تتحدث
عن ان السياره او مركبه يستقلها مسلحان قد
اطلقاها النار على سياره المستوطنين
وانحرفت الى الجانب الاخر من الشارع وصدمت
باحدى السيارات وكان هناك اطلاق نار اضافي
على من مسافه السفر على المستوطنين واجهزه
عليهما في داخل هذه المركبه التي تحمل
لوحه ترخيص اسرائيليه في الشارع ومن ثم لا
ذائب الفرار من هذا من المكان وهناك روايه
اخرى تتحدث بان الشاب يعت مكتوب عليه شعار
او مرسوم عليه شعار عرين الاسود قد يترجل
من احدى السيارات واطلق النار من مسافه
صفر على هذين المستوطنين وقتلهما في داخل
المركبه ولكن الجيش الاحتلال هرع الى
المكان بقوات كبيره وقد قام بعمليات اغلاق
عديد الحواجز المؤديه الى مدينه نابلس
وذلك في عمل في بحث وتمشيط عن هذين
المنفذين او المنفذ لهذه العمليه وايضا
هناك طائرات من دروند
تحلق في سماء الشارع الرئيسي ببلده حواره
هذه العمليه او هذا الهجوم وقع عند مفترق
بلده عينبوس وهو الذي يقع في داخل الشارع
الرئيسي في داخل بلده حواره والذي يسلكه
جميع المستوطنين الذين يتنقلون بين
المستوطنات المحيطه بمدينه نابلس وايضا
بين حاجزي زعتره وايضا الحوار في جنوبي
المدينه وبالتالي هناك ايضا ثكنات عسكريه
ودوريات عسكريه دائما منتشره في هذا
الشارع هذا الهجوم ان كان هناك تنفيذ لهذا
الهجوم بهذا الشكل فانه في وضع النهار
بهذا الشكل
فانه يعتبر حسب الفلسطينيين هجوما نوعيا
في ظل هذه الحاله الامنيه القويه والمكثفه
في هذا الشارع بالتحديد الذي يسلكه
المستوطنين في كل لحظه هناك ايضا دعوات من
قبل وزيره الاستيطان الاسرائيليه وايضا ما
يعرف برئيس مجلس مستوطنات شمال الضفه
الغربيه الذي دعا الحكومه الايطاليه
للانتقال من عمليات الدفاع الى الهجوم
وايضا دعايا الجانب او الوفد الاسرائيلي
الذي يمثل سلطات الاحتلال في داخل في قمه
العقبه اليوم للانسحاب فورا ردا على هذا
الهجوم الذي نفذه الفلسطينيون باتجاه
المستوطنين وقد تم قتلهما في المكان هناك
ايضا اغلاق للمكان كما ذكرنا ليله وهناك
عمليه تنشيط وايضا كان هناك احتفالات
بمدينه جنين ومخيمها وايضا في مدينه نابلس
وذلك بتوزيع الحلوى ابتهاجا واحتفالا بهذا
الهجوم الجديد النوعي حسب الفلسطينيين
باتجاه او ضد المستوطنين الذين هم دائما
هم يعتدون على الفلسطينيين وممتلكات وخاصه
في محيط مدينه نابلس والذي شاهدناه
شاهدناه يوم امس باعتداء على المواطنين في
قريه بغورين واحرق بعض المركبات والاعتداء
على منزلهم شكرا لك مراسلنا سمير ابو
شمالي من رام الله